[Musique]
l'église de sainte-marie devaient être
fermés il y a dix mois mais les
francophones d'elliot lake résiste
l'église joue un très grand rôle dans le
maintien de la visite c'est absolument
dans l'ontario les listes à un moment
c'est 1 1 1 1 et d'entités que les
français existe je pense que c'est dans
notre dans notre coeur de continuer
d'attirer de garder le père anthony a
appris le français en immigrants au
canada de la guyane britannique misère
les deux paroisses catholiques d'elliot
lake langue l'aise et la française qui
doivent maintenant fusionné leur
histoire remonte depuis des années des
années des années alors je comprends
leur fierté de vivre en français ici et
je voudrais tant que possible contribuer
mais deux scènes là dessus aussi
elliot lake est née au milieu des années
en même temps que l'industrie d'uranium
on venait de partout au canada pour
travailler dans les mines
je reviens ici je suis à peine 18 ans
jacques baijot ni jamais retourné dans
sa gaspésie natale
cela fait 60 ans qu'il se bat pour ne
pas perdre sa langue
quand je peux parler français un anglais
je le fais avec un sourire qui chôment
ce qu'ils essaient de me répondre en
français
j'atteins on nous donne pas notre
français m'ont été acceptée d'exister
dès le début les francophones aide à
construire la ville et se battent pour
avoir leur propre paroisse on espère dit
fils et du saint-esprit l'église
sainte-marie ouvre ses portes au début
des années 70 grâce à la persévérance de
paroissiens qui tienne
prié en français tu es de pouvoir vivre
ma vie selon mon héritage et des biens
dans mon pot de ce pas pourquoi mais on
est programmé de tout de suite changé à
l'autre langue
mais faudrait bien qu'on fait pour ça
beaucoup de fois parce que ça dit oui
notre langue ça détruit la manière corps
seraient celles de bonne foi madame rose
eto'o a participé au comité de
transition qui prépare la fusion des
paroisses la création d'une nouvelle
entité bilingue elle a démissionné après
quelques mois c'était toujours un
anglais peut-être toujours des
francophones qui devrait expliquer leur
position en anglais pour moi elle
franco-ontarienne c'est vraiment une
grande grande fierté
une fierté dans la différence papillon
fabry est né à elliot lake et a choisi
après des études au québec de revenir
ici pour élever sa famille
on
quatre beaux enfants qui viennent à la
messe tous les dimanches
guillaume qui a 8 ans va célébrer sa
première communion en janvier m'a montré
nos enfants c'est d'être fiers dans la
différence notre voisin arrive elle
arrive du sud de l'ontario puis leur ai
dit alors oui comme si nos enfants
étaient sourds ils sont pas sourcées que
des beaucoup beaucoup d'incompréhension
et de solides sites existent j'essaie de
lui expliquer l'anglais ils vont
apprendre ça s'attrape papillon s'oppose
farouchement à la fusion des paroisses
pour elle quand une institution est
bilingue
l'anglais prend forcément le dessus
l'assimilation deviennent inévitables
les services en français et qu on en eut
un exemple avec le bulletin paroissial
on est ayant essayé de créer un bulletin
bilingue on était relégué à la page 7
à toi père tu es un dieu éternel et tout
puissant août rend possible la messe
sera célébrée en français et pas
bilingue est ce que vous comprenez leur
peur de perdre leur langue s'ils perdent
leur paroisse oui parce que les
occasions qu'ils auront pour s'exprimer
seront diminués un certain point et aux
stocks ont réduit le les occasions ça
risque avoir des problèmes pour garantir
de garder leur culture la langue aussi
[Musique]
on le garde nos grands parrains pour
garder nos pareil toute leur vie se sont
battus nous autres on va laisser faire
maintenant j'en crois pas
[Musique]
ce bâtiment ici a été construit par la
génération de mes parents des pionniers
c'est un édifice qui est solide c'est un
édifice qui est beau c'est difficile de
le laisser partir ce bâtiment là c'est
important pour moi dans encore d'avoir
nos églises ici dans l'ontario faut que
ça continue
autant que possible pour notre identité
[Musique]